welcome to this video playing piece
death let's play the no pain Queens
gambit accepted now we get a really
wacky line can I go age 4 or not yeah I
basically have to check I know it looks
completely completely a thick but it
isn't it is a line this check and this
huh and takes it how sick is this okay
Bishop d6 I guess yeah the black king is
some is a very student in a very strange
spot but many other things are also
weird how do I play this and what is my
king doing them hmm is he going to go
see forward hmm
could g4 might be an option
yeah that's maybe a threat actually very
very strange
well I played f 6m I'm the one to blame
for this nonsense could have played
something solid as well but I didn't
want to so just you form yeah maybe just
to form I can go all the way to h2 well
maybe you should asics is not such a bad
development for this that's 697 maybe
yeah so going back here I don't think
the c5 is not going to be that much of a
problem just so did you fire this a
little bit yeah the problem is that my
queen down is it that great I doubt it I
really doubt it yeah maybe and do this
sb5 an option for me OS is insane well I
mean I don't know come on it might be
really really bad but might also be a
good idea we cannot remove that pawn and
maybe I can really take end and do stuff
taketake Bishop before something like
that or be sure before immediately at
least set some problems
yeah you never know what to make of a
queen a meg Meg of Queen on h2 like that
it binds and irritates but it's also
kind of a little bit off and some when
this what is the point I don't get it am
I not just breaking through there now
all night 9600 96 that could be the
problem whoa can you six CD five and six
is unprotected no oh here's shooting for
work h1 but that's not a problem who
catch one I can take and then Bishop c4
winning some Bishop c4 now yeah when yes
compensation anyway even if you just
just wraps if you just stir this yeah
right right right right he's still
threatening the hook h1 business and
queen a seven okay Queen 87 I can play
book c7 that's not super dangerous
check I'm not sure if that was best
really I think he probably had something
better now i'm getting active I thought
rook age one would be would have been
better I mean okay maybe I'm just
overlooking things and but I thought
that could have been much worse actually
this threatens rupee five
time is about equal rugby 595 where is
he going then to d6 Queen 85 check poor
I can also just take this yeah come on
keep it the debt to savings and not a
bad one now as Bishop is really bad and
I don't have to worry about something
drastic happening okay three is a nice
little threat time morning check 96 e
foil the ship will go to f1 ok so maybe
maybe this one Queen a five in the mix
and the check there
looks very problematic actually rookie
one and this C 4 and C for now for that
night it looks difficult to defend check
check no stay man no stalemates please
check check white resigns okay there was
a very very strange game yeah that
opening line is this is quite a funny
one this should be five years I'm kind
of pseudo trom pls no knight on f6 yeah
but ok that's playable and this is a
very strange line but it's very
interesting as black is aiming to get
the bishops very quickly yeah they know
h5 and he he went with this this is
really a this is really really
theoretically explored yeah but I don't
really know how it continues I think
this is really a this is something that
has been seen before but ok I can I can
take on g 1 F 2 well that makes much
more sense actually ok
what a strange opening 92 m ya know he
went here which does seem passive I was
actually expecting this one I have to go
I for now I guess and since this is
really strange this position I have no
idea what's happening I mean that kick
looks very funny but it's so
unconventional I have no idea again yeah
now I felt I should be somewhat okay
interesting the engine ha b5 it's
actually interesting really interesting
just stopping c4 probably a good idea
okay I went like this and I didn't think
about the zero or I just thought okay
and the engine gives equal not equal I'm
curious about might be five movers this
is any good at least the computer is not
objecting to it wants to go rookie one
yeah rupee one is the best move here
then be five words at least playable it
gives equal now this King up king cakes
yeah now this is much better for white
because after well I i did this and now
he has to go look aged one this is the
big issue he took and this is wrong it
gives me a crucial tempo here this is
much better Queen I don't have a great
square also problem um yeah like this
for example i can t yeah check do this
this is a line that I saw
I have to do something well I don't know
something here he invades and I'm
passive that's very good and here now
everything is to completely turned
around no black as much better yeah in
fact Winningham winning yeah this was an
interesting moment I took I took on d3
that was a good decision I guess this
was also interesting I wasn't entirely
sure about this year I couldn't
calculate this wins chance this is made
in one even home yeah well but this is
not bad it just keeps I mean it just
controls the position like have some
very good advantage the night is just
stronger and I have threads yeah and now
is there too to destination squares for
that piece and the bishop is not quick
enough to cover them so it's a win yeah
very very very good game thanks for
watching